how's it going bro Sandra my name is
Pierre fat welcome to 1916 flare rifle
equipped gas mask huh let's go Laden
what finger down lighten up man let's go
I'm pumped up so pump that's fine no
matter
oh man Wow let's find the ladder
oh man I'm so slow gas masks on find out
Aladdin oh oh man oh my [ __ ]
not honey huh what the [ __ ] was that
uh what the [ __ ] ah I don't think we're
gonna be friggin decide this
[ __ ] dinosaurs here I get their
[ __ ] it's the [ __ ] line is already
leading me oh [ __ ]
finding that light and know either
dinosaurs and why does it game stand
hell may have weapons when I don't why
oh okay why the [ __ ] did I go there
gotta liven miss I know now we open Wow
sorry my computer decided to be [ __ ]
for a second okay welcome back I I
almost don't know what to get what
happened okay Laden
findell are allowed and that's Pitino
[Music]
spinderella Laden yeah let's try not get
eaten by the fridge and dinosaurs holy
cow
what is this Mike Dean is that you
nothing I'm doing something here
I took his frickin hand for some reason
why something in his ass okay we're
gonna know what to do one bomber leaving
water by Dennis on happened inhalation
time gamma my German isn't that great
so there are dinosaurs that freaking
dinosaurs don't laugh at me
okay having your hand bra I have your
friggin hand me and Richard had it going
at his way me and [ __ ] had it
oh no no no no no Oh penis penis penis
penis penis penis penis penis oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] dinosaur is my aunt okay
where do you miss their head and go
[ __ ] dinosaurs man
klaudia that sounds pretty sweet get the
[ __ ] out of here okay here we go
liebherr buddha isn't some Dyke Martinez
good night and I mean ah yes yes so am i
picking up why am i picking up his hand
oh wait I have me backing it with the
design of mr. hand Master Hand let's go
to Natalie okay wait am i walking
backwards this it's a flare not sweet an
ammo I need a gun though okay okay
this way let's go it's you and me mr.
Han dad go what the heck are you guys
doing are there holding hands is gay
couple huh gay couple eating my down oh
sorry makes I'm okay take all those
Flyers you'll need them pretty oh come
on
it's just dinosaurs it's just dinosaurs
where's that Aladdin oh man this isn't
sound good
I need the gas mask any Jasmine [ __ ] get
out of here okay let's go
I get it thought it was gonna die that
okay where's the gas line it's fine
together man okay maybe in the bunker
oh let's do this mr. fan it's you and me
buddy
between the many adventures before we
never fought the dinosaurs looks like my
hand like a pack listen I love you have
a freakin gas mask [ __ ] the [ __ ] man
take it easy with the bombing I'm right
here hey guys
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
we're supposed to go through leta Jeff
ah yes and there's a gas
no idea what I just picked up but
[Music]
if it's a gas mask then I'm happy it's
not a gas pickup
[Applause]
bro can have your gas mask bro
my life stars Mouton and solidyne
battery only in Russian is Solomon what
okay I'm a freakin what the [ __ ]
take it take it you can have it I don't
care I'm out of here
I was a [ __ ] manager [ __ ] those
dinosaurs man [ __ ] dinosaurs
everywhere
asko over here okay I don't think we've
been there oh [ __ ] Jesus cries I'm right
here so boring oh man okay
what sir it's a [ __ ] piano good job
whoever put the [ __ ] channel there
taking your hand bro hey don't scare me
like man I just want your hand
can I have your hand bro it's not okay
the visa or Ola duel the king kelana
cough cough Ilana pinky bond over the
table top at the pad a big puff of do
for Hank Neff okay so this others gasp
come on I need to get man
I heard dinosaurs
I hear dinosaurs
okay what uh-oh hey bro
gotta 894
okay let's go - all right okay huh oh
you [ __ ] dinosaur give me the gas
mask [ __ ] dinosaur back off
[ __ ] okay oh okay oh it's on now
[ __ ] oh yeah you better believe he's on
oh okay maybe it's not on it it was a
little off oh okay I just ran there I
surrender
find the doll Layton no fun do I have my
gas mask no I don't have my stop [ __ ]
I'm finding out of here
okay
find that that Layton no no that's
pretty man I'm thinking your handle care
if you don't like it
thank you hello is rain how you damn
pity my files vanish uh take that I'm
going to Natalie ye and then we're going
to Louisa I'm taking your hand bro I
don't care if you don't lag in hello my
strain okay we're just Louisa this way I
just found the gas mask and then
freaking dinosaurs gets me that's my
luck okay
a couple seen those before and then we
go to the air okay
my god whoa
gangsters bride a mom okay okay okay
and then Billy Anna no we need the gas
this is all those friggin dinosaur
doesn't show up again let's face it's
it's most likely will Italy they will
show oh wait let me see you wasn't it
this way oh this is piano and then I
went off the wall doing bra much for
hand you're my only frame oh it's this
way right no no we're here where did we
find the [ __ ] gas masks
I don't remember
come on
come on let's go to Billy Emma no I
can't cuz there's gas in this way maybe
can't miss this place
oh yeah I'm back here [ __ ] great ok
let's go to Louisiana are we are in
Louisa this place is very nice
are you doing bra let me have slap here
okay maybe that didn't work oh look I
can see moe
come on don't [ __ ] scare me like that
okay let's go to Borat that night yes
[Music]
huh
take it let's go let's go to Millie Amma
[ __ ] quick
it's time to go to Billy Anna put on the
gas mask Brock yeah I'm badass I'm bad
freakin ass
I'm even in water
went there I mean to water but I'm
badass okay what ah [ __ ] dinosaurs
run run run
oh don't leg out on me now please okay
good take it okay run run run
they're lovin be analyzing it no yes no
be they that allow them yes yeah Nazis I
don't care
I'm Wayne okay I died anyway but
whatever that was pretty badass that was
pretty bad and we're gonna go
[Music]
Oh what
for what alright so that was 1969
finding dead Aladdin hope you enjoyed
thumbs up the video and I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
walking paradox threesomes with a
[ __ ] Triceratops wrecked our weapon
as a mark and death rock stars -
ecstatic wigs made of